the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hello and welcome to 507 biochemistry on
MIT OpenCourseWare I'm dr. Bob danfa
delish
let's metabolize some problems this
series of videos is meant to supplement
some of the other materials on the site
and to give you a more in-depth and more
interactive take on some of the topics
covered in 507 biochemistry specifically
we're going to be working together
through one problem from each problem
set from this course
today we're discussing the very first
homework problem of 507 which is problem
1 or problem set 1 this problem is meant
to give you a better sense of the scales
and dimensions of the cellular
environment specifically we're going to
be asking questions like how big is a
cell what is the volume of a cell and
how many molecules of a given protein
are inside a cell
what a fundamental idea introduced in
this problem is that the cellular
environment is very crowded things
inside the cell are very tightly packed
now take a look at this picture in your
book as you see here the constituents of
a cell like proteins enzymes the
organelles metabolites are all in very
close proximity to each other now this
is also reflected in the concentration
that were given for the proteins inside
the cell the problem tells us there are
350 milligrams per milliliter of protein
or in other words 250 grams per liter
now this is a very high number in the
context of biochemistry basically if you
think one liter is a thousand grams then
350 grams of that is protein so we have
250 grams 35% of a cell is protein and
only 60 to 65% is water therefore as the
problem says when we're doing in vitro
experiments using dilute solutions we
rarely recapitulate what actually
happens inside the cell know how big is
a mammalian cell as you will see sizes
of cells in an organism vary
considerably at one extreme we have very
tiny cells like endothelial cells red
blood cells these are very very small
but the other end we have like the
reproductive cells like the egg which is
100 to 200 microns in diameter
whatever the cells that can stretch four
centimeters like the muscle cells and
certain nerve cells now in this problem
we're going to be dealing with the red
blood cells one of the most abundant
cells in the body as you can see in this
very colorful picture a red blood cell
can be approximated by a cylinder six to
eight microns in diameter right so
knowing that we can actually calculate
some dimensions of the red blood cells
such as the total volume and their
surface area
now here is a cylinder by which we
approximate a red blood cell and let's
say this cylinder has the height H and
the radius R from our problem we know H
is about two microns and R well we know
the diameter it's like six to eight
microns so R is gonna be let's go is the
middle 3.5 microns now as you remember
from from geometry then the volume of
the cylinder is gonna be PI R squared H
which when we substitute our units we're
gonna get about 77 cubic microns all
right we'll come back to discussing the
units in a little bit now the surface
area so it's gonna be the area
surrounding the cylinder plus the two
circles on top in the bottom so the two
circles are two PI R squared plus the
surrounding area it's gonna be 2 PI R H
and that comes out to be about a hundred
twenty four ninety five square microns
now how much is really one cubic micron
let's try to relate it to a unit that
we're more familiar such as leader right
so well one milliliter is actually one
cubic centimeter right one microliter is
one cubic millimeter
now one cubic micrometer it's like a
billion times smaller than one
microliter one way because it's already
a millions times smaller than leader so
this is really 10 to the minus 15
leaders is one cubic micro leave the
micrometer which is 10 to the minus 15
is the femto unit so it's like 1 femto
leader now 77 femto leaders and it's an
incredibly small volume but as we'll see
next when we look at bacteria bacteria
are even smaller now let's take a look
at a staph aureus cell now
Staphylococcus aureus is a very common
bacteria than we often find on our skin
or in our respiratory tract now this is
the same bacteria that you might have
heard in the acronym MRSA or
methicillin-resistant Staph aureus
now this MRSA is a pathogenic bacteria
that can cause a lot of problems in the
hospitals nowadays because it is
resistant to most of the antibiotics
that we have now here is a picture of
staph aureus as you can see it's a
spherical cell and of course this pretty
purple color is added in this is just a
electron micrograph picture of a colony
of staph aureus bacteria so for it to we
can calculate the volume of the cell and
the surface area if we assume staph
aureus to be a sphere of radius R we are
told our is point 6 microns then we can
calculate the volume of the cell the
volume is simply going to be 4 PI R
cubed over 3 and if we plug in the
numbers we're gonna get zero point 1 1
cubic micrometer
similarly for the surface area the
surface area of a sphere it's 4 PI R
squared and the units come out to one
point one three square microns
now 0.11 cubed microns and we said a
cubic micron is one femto leaders like
10 to minus 15 liters so 0.1 one cubic
micrometers is 110 times 10 to minus 18
litres now the prefix for 10 to minus 18
that's Alto
so it's 110 out of leaders this is an
incredibly small volume so by
calculating the volume and the surface
area of these cells we've essentially
answered part 1 and part 2 of this
problem now next we're going to explore
the relationship between the volume and
the surface area of the cell
as you know from geometry the volume
typically varies with the cube of the
radius whereas the surface area varies
only was the square of the radius
therefore as the radius of an object
increases the ratio surface area over
volume will decrease because the volume
increases quicker now this is exactly
what we observe with cells therefore for
a red blood cell surface area over
volume it's going to be 120 95 square
microns over 70/7 cubic microns that
comes out to about 1.6 inverse microns
now for a staph aureus cell surface area
over volume it's gonna be one point
thirteen square microns over point one
one cubic microns that's approximately
it's approximately ten why is this
important it's because the surface area
was cell controls how fast molecules can
go in and out of the cell it essentially
controls the flux of molecules across
the cell membrane now if the surface
area over volume is a large number it
means the molecules can access that
volume fairly quickly and efficiently
but as you can see the bigger the cell
the smaller the surface area of a volume
number becomes and therefore for big
cells molecules will have a hard time
and will take a long time to get inside
the cell or out of the cell that's why
Nature has designed ways to transport
molecules to make them achieve the right
concentration efficiently now this is
why in the case of bigger cells such as
the eukaryotic cells or mammalian cells
in our case that red blood cells Nature
has evolved transport mechanisms by
which it can deliver small molecules
throughout the entire volume of the cell
one example of such transfer molecules
is hemoglobin which is used to deliver
oxygen this is what we're going to take
a look at next
we are given that hemoglobin constitutes
95% of the proteins in a red blood cells
so let's calculate the concentration of
hemoglobin in a red blood cell now let's
start with the average protein
concentration in the cell which we'll
mentioned earlier which was 350
milligrams per milliliter
now if 95% of this is hemoglobin then
the concentration of hemoglobin is going
to be about 322 milligrams per
milliliter all right now I'm gonna
abbreviate hemoglobin that's HB we're
told that hemoglobin has a molecular
weight of 67,000 Dalton's which is
another way of saying 67,000 grams per
mole all right so then the concentration
of hemoglobin it's gonna be 322
milligrams per 67 thousand grams per
mole is the same as milligrams per milli
mole and per milliliter the grams go
away and we get zero point zero zero
four eight it's gonna be millimole per
milliliter that's the same as mole per
liter that's the molar concentration or
we can write it four point eight milli
molar now this is a pretty important
range to keep in mind because the most
abundant proteins such as hemoglobin are
gonna be in the low millimolar range
most of the other proteins are gonna be
in the micromolar range in a cell now
let's calculate how many molecules of
hemoglobin we have in a red blood cell
so we calculated before that the volume
of a red blood cell is actually 77 femto
leaders that's once again 77 times 10 to
minus 15 leaders now we know in this
volume the concentration of hemoglobin
is 4.8 milli molar so we can calculate
the number of moles so new number of
moles is gonna be the concentration
times the volume okay so we have four
point eight million molar times 77 times
10 to minus 15 liters equals now of
course milli molar we have to transform
this back into molar we have multiple
leaders the leaders are gonna cancel out
so I'm gonna get moles and it's three
hundred sixty nine or so times ten to
minus eighteen moles okay remember ten
to minus eighteen that's a de moles so
369 animals of hemoglobin we have in a
red blood cell now we know one mole
contains the Avogadro numbers of
molecules so if you multiply this with
the Avogadro number we should get the
actual number of molecules so number of
molecules is just mo Gaudreau number
times number of moles and I forgot the
number it's approximately six point zero
two two times ten to the 23rd power it's
a gigantic number times three sixty nine
times ten to the minus 18 moles we're
gonna get about 2.2 times ten to the
eighth molecules
so or in other words this is at 220
million molecules so the problem was
telling us about a Google search in
which we came up four different numbers
and one of them was two thousand one of
them two was 200 million
so obviously the answer we got 220
million is closer to the two to three
hundred million molecules that at Google
search returned that's the answer for
that part of the problem
finally let's see how the size of a
hemoglobin molecule compares to the size
of a cell
we're told he mo globin is roughly
spherical in shape
with a diameter of about 55 angstrom now
as we recall from intro to chemistry one
angstrom is ten to the minus ten meters
that's 0.1 nanometer so our radius here
is going to be well half the diameter so
it's 27.5 angstrom is 2.75 nanometers
all right so the volume of a hemoglobin
molecule is going to be 4 PI R cubed
over 3 and we're plugging in 2.75
nanometers so it's gonna come up to be
eight point seven times ten to the minus
eight cubic microns all right now you
remember the volume of a red blood cell
was 77 cubic microns so if you look at
the relationship between the two
well how many volumes of a hemoglobin
can we fit in a red blood cell well we
just divided volume out the red blood
cell to the form a hemoglobin 77 over
eight point seven nine ten to the minus
eight both are cubic microns and that
gives us eight point eight times ten to
the eighth molecules
okay so this is 880 million molecules of
hemoglobin would fit in the volume of a
red blood cell well if only hemoglobin
would be in there obviously this number
is an overestimation because when you're
packing spherical objects they're not
gonna pack very tightly with each other
and as we said the shape is only
approximately spherical but nevertheless
it's on the same order of magnitude as
the two to three hundred million
molecules of hemoglobin that we
calculated earlier based on the
concentration so from both the volume
standpoint and concentration standpoint
we now have calculated how many
molecules of hemoglobin can fit in the
red blood cell this result would just
God actually highlights a very important
take-home message which is if we look at
the molecular and atomic scale it is s
distance from the cellular scale as the
cellular scale is different from the
macroscopic scale now if we take one
milliliter of blood we find a few
billion red blood cells inside it now
within each red blood cells we find
hundreds of millions of molecules such
as hemoglobin that's it for this problem
I hope you now have a better sense of
the sizes and scales relevant for
biochemistry and cell biology in general
keep in mind our discussion of the
surface area to volume ratio and why as
the cell size gets bigger we need
transport mechanisms to make sure the
nutrients and metabolites get to where
they need to go efficiently also keep in
mind some of the concentration ranges
that we discussed as these will become
very important in understanding the
biological significance of some of the
constants that we're going to calculate
for enzymes later in the course